uh should we be afraid of these high
numbers should we be worried that
there's so many viruses in the world
well to a certain extent i mean they
have it's twofold they're good and bad
right viruses are no there's no question
they can be bad we know that because
they've infected and caused disease
throughout history but we're also you
and i are full of viruses that don't
hurt us at all and probably help us and
every organism is the same so they are
clearly beneficial as a consequence so i
think
so every living thing on the planet has
multiple viruses infecting everything
you can see
and
most of them i think we don't worry
about
because they can't infect us they're
unable in fact
now you could actually you can actually
take your feces and send them to a
company and they will sequence your
viruses in your feces for you your fecal
firearm right
and
the most
common
virus in human feces is a plant virus
that infects peppers
it's called pepper model mosaic virus
and that's because people eat a lot of
peppers and it just passes right through
you cabbage is full of viruses from the
insects that walk on the cabbage in the
fields we eat them they just pass us so
i think most of the viruses we don't
need to worry about except when we're
talking about species that are closest
to us mammals of course
i and i think the most numerous ones are
the most concerning they're viruses like
bats bats are 20 of mammals and rodents
are 40
of mammals and we humans
live nearby right yeah and we know
throughout history many viruses have
come from bats and from rodents to
people no question about it there's a
proximity in terms of just living
together in a proximity genetically to
so it's more likely a virus will jump
from a bat in the road and birds too
birds can give us their viruses that's
happened you know influenza viruses come
from birds mainly so i think those are
the three
species
not species it's higher than species
obviously but those are the three i
would worry about in terms of getting
their viruses and we don't really know
what's out there right we have very
little clue about what viruses and i've
for years wanted to capture wild mice in
my backyard and see what viruses they
have because no one knows
wait
and it's you can't ask them so you mean
map uh like is there a way to test them
yeah no i have to would have to
sacrifice them and take tissue and then
bring it in the lab and do genome
sequencing so you can do a
thorough sequencing to determine which
viruses is there a sufficiently good
categorization of viruses where you'd be
that's a very good question so whenever
you do sequence right you get some
environmental sample and you extract
nucleic acid and you sequence it what
you do is you run it past the database
with the gold standard is the genbank
database which is maintained here in the
u.s
and you see if you get any hits
and then you can say ah look this this
sequence is similar to this virus and
you can classify all the viruses you see
the problem is
of your sequence is dark matter it
doesn't hit with anything it's probably
a lot of it is unknown viruses and
that's gonna be hard to figure out
because someone's gonna have to go after
it and sort it through so yes you can
find a lot of viruses and the numbers
you get are astounding you can find
thousands of new viruses just by looking
in various life forms but
there are many more that we don't pick
up because they're not in the database
you